Hello everybody and welcome to episode
number 15 of my road to one bill series.
Uh today we're starting off by doing
some gnome restaurant which I have
finally figured out. Took actually like
four or five hours to get it down
properly and I did make a video about it
so I'm not going to go over it too much
in the road to unill series. Uh but
we'll go briefly just summarize.
Basically what we're doing is we're
going to uh these two gnomes and
delivering them food after we have
everything set up. Uh, you can get about
20 of these gnomes orders complete in an
hour and there's about a 1 in 20 chance
of receiving a gnome scarf. Uh, which is
worth about 800k. Uh, so altogether I
was getting close to 1 mil an hour doing
this. It is a bit of a pain for some
things. Uh, but honestly, I kind of
found it a bit fun surprisingly. Uh, so
some goals for this episode are we're
going to do a couple quests. We want to
get my arms big adventure done. And uh
we want to get our cash check up to 10
mil. Uh and get that green cash status.
I think coming up here, we're actually
getting our first gnome scarf. Yep,
there it is. Which is pretty exciting.
Uh I was pretty stoked when I finally
got that. Also, it just looks really
cool if you equip it. And uh yeah, we'll
price check it quickly, but I think it's
worth about 800k as of this video. Yeah,
so not bad. And yeah, let's get the
episode started. All right, guys. One
more thing before we jump into the video
is uh we did do a draw for a one month
GE Tracker membership. Almost a hundred
of you entered which is really awesome.
Thank you all for the support on that
last video. Uh so we've loaded up all
your names on here and we will spin to
see who actually is going to win the
membership. And the winner is going to
be
DPJ. Congratulations. You have won one
month of G Tracker. Uh give it one or
two days for it to upgrade. will make
sure to get your account upgraded as
soon as possible. All right, thanks
everyone for entering. All right, guys,
that we got our second gnome scarf. That
was probably only five more runs, so
really not that bad. It was actually
only another 20 minutes after our last
one, so we kind of lucked out there.
There is our second gnome scarf. That is
another 800k. And we're rocking the
Santa hat because it's Christmas time
and why not? So, after that uh second
gnome scarf, we kind of went on a dry
streak. So, we decided to do some
agility and uh we grinded out for a
couple hours and we did hit 55 marks of
grace uh which is pretty exciting
because that is our second to last uh
graceful piece. So, all we have left is
the hood after this and then we'll have
the full set uh which we've been kind of
working towards for almost a month or
two now. And yeah, pretty exciting. All
right, we're in Graceful's uh Grace's
graceful clothing and we're going to buy
the graceful top. There we go. Perfect.
And uh yeah, that is our second to last
piece. going to reduce down our weight
to minus 20. We're getting less fat
every day, which is pretty nice. And uh
yeah, we'll just have to get the
graceful hood and then we'll be totally
complete. All right, so we're actually
just hitting an agility level. There is
57 agility. Uh we're still trying to
grind out the graceful set tonight. Uh
we're not we got we got a fair amount
more marks to get, but uh yeah, there's
an agility level. All right, so I just
noticed actually after doing the couple
hours of gnome restaurant, we got about
2 mill in profit from those gnome
scarves and some extras. And that
actually brought us up past 10 mil. So
we finally have a green cash stack.
We're now 1/100th of the way to one
bill. So you know, we're pretty close
any day now. And uh yeah, we're going to
knock off the rest of these agility uh
levels and agility marks more
importantly uh so we can get the full
graceful set. We're just buying some
alkals here, but uh yeah, let's go ahead
and do it. All right, so we're back at
the canifice course. Uh we're very close
to having 35 marks of grace. Uh but
we're actually going to hit an agility
level just before that. We finally kind
of got this aling and agility thing
down. Uh so we're not losing too much
agility experience. Uh cuz it ended up
affecting our experience levels quite a
bit. Anyway, there is 58 agility. All
right. And there is our last mark of
grace. That is 35. That is all we need
for the graceful set. So we'll go ahead
and go to Graceful's graceful outfit. I
think that's right. And buy the final
piece. All right. Here we are, guys. It
has been a couple months since I started
on this goal. And there we go. The
graceful hood is the last piece. So,
just in case you didn't know, having the
full graceful set does have a added
bonus beyond just the weight reduction
of the individual pieces. So, it's going
to cap out at minus 20 or - 24, whatever
it is. But, we also get 30% increased
run energy restoration, which is going
to be pretty sweet for almost
everything. So, it kind of seems like I
have about uh 10 mil just kind of laying
around, not doing anything. Uh, so I
kind of decided that I would kind of
throw back to an older uh money-making
method I did before. And that is going
to be buying some Odium shards and
combining them into an ODM ward. Um, and
so we're just going to calculate this by
adding up the uh average buy price of
the three pieces and then uh subtracting
that off of the price of what we can
sell the odium ward for. Uh, I did have
a moneymaking guide for this. So, if
you're actually interested in how to do
it, there's I'm going to have to
link so much stuff. Just It's on my
channel. You can go find it. Uh, but
yeah, it actually works pretty well. You
can see here we're actually going to get
about 350k in profit just by uh
essentially just flipping. We're just
kind of doing a complicated way of
flipping an item. Uh, but all you have
to do is run into the top right corner
of the map and um there's a volcano and
you can turn it into the full product
and then you get 300k in profit. So, not
too bad. We're going to go ahead and put
an offer in hopefully for two of each.
Although, I'm not sure if I actually be
able to afford that cuz one of the
pieces did rise up quite a lot in the
last month or so and but it's still
profitable surprisingly. So, while we
wait for our pieces to buy, we're just
going to do a little bit more gnome
restaurant. Uh, it's been pretty good to
us the last couple hours we've done it.
So, I don't know, maybe we'll get
another scarf. I'm not sure if that's
how RNG works at all. Uh, but we'll go
ahead and try for some more. All right,
so our first delivery is going to yield
us a two half of a key. That's actually
not too bad. That's like
20k. Way better than some. For our
second delivery, we got a gnome ball.
And I always think this is the expensive
item. Unfortunately, this one's not
worth anything. Good 4.4K. And our third
delivery is a bird's nest. Man, that's a
weird succession of items we just got,
but I don't know, not complaining. All
right, so we ended up doing another 10
of those and didn't get anything as a
reward. So, I think instead we're going
to work on the uh prerequisites for the
my arms big adventure quest. And I think
the only one left we have to do is
jungle potion, uh, which is a pretty
quick quest. So, we'll go knock that out
of the way. All right, so somehow we
searched some rocks and found a herb in
there, which is cool with me. All right,
I think that is jungle potion complete.
one quest point and 775 herbal
experience, but mainly we're doing it so
we can do the miniame and do my arms big
adventure. So, we are at Mount Doom. We
are going to combine the three Odium
pieces into the Odium ward. Uh, which is
a nice 300k profit right there. Not too
bad. Uh, we'll go back to the Grand
Exchange and sell it. Okay, so we ended
up selling it maybe only for a 200 or
250k profit, but still pretty good for
the amount of work we put in anyway. Uh,
so I think we're going to go ahead and
buy another Odium Shard 2 and three. Uh,
that way we can buy another ward and get
another two or 300k in profit.
Afterwards, we are going to continue on
with the typo want to clean up miniame.
Uh, cuz we do need it for the my arms
pick adventure quest. Oh my god, there's
so many syllables and all this stuff.
So, I think this is the most effective
way to do it. We are chopping down the
jungle vines and then killing anything
that spawns and then just dropping the
uh the sticks or whatever you get. So, I
got this goat tuber. I don't never heard
of this item before, but it's worth
521k. What the Okay, there is 63%
favor in the tabana cleanup miniame so
we can go ahead and start my big
adventure. And we got 23 trading sticks
as well. All right, I still cannot get
over how much this goaty goat tuber is
worth. It's actually going to sell for
about 500k, which is insane. Uh, we do
have the two pieces for the odium ward
as well. So, we'll go ahead and combine
those. All right, we're back at the
volcanic forge. Uh, we'll combine the
three pieces. And that is another 300k
profit, which is pretty nice. I can't
recommend this method enough, even
though I did kind of get some flak for
this one, but uh, it still works. Can
still do it, guys. It doesn't crash
forever. All right, so before we're
starting the My Arms Big Adventure
quest, we are going to gather some camel
dung uh because we do need it for the
quest. And apparently can't get it
anywhere else. Can we take this abyssal
whip? Come on, take
it. Oh, wow. I think I kicked this out
of the cut scene. All right, so we're
about halfway done this quest, and it is
pretty annoying. I'll be completely
honest. Uh the cut scenes are hilarious.
Everything about is pretty funny, but is
a lot of running and weird things. All
right, this guy is throwing a serious
tender tantrum. I kind of like how he
just cons people all the way
like boom. Danny's gone. All right, so
we are nearing the end of the quest. We
just have to fight this big bird, which
uh apparently isn't too big a deal, but
uh he does knock you back, which is
really annoying. And I I can't click on
him. This is actually kind of annoying.
Okay, so we did end up killing the bird,
which is good. And we got the reward
which is burnt meat which I hope is the
troll and he should give me the
experience. Uh what? Okay, so apparently
we have to talk to my arm and he will
actually give me the experience and uh
the quest
completion. All right, there we go. My
arm's big adventure is completed. So we
have access to the disease free patch,
10k herbar experience, and 5k farming.
Uh mainly we're doing it for the patch,
but the experience is always nice.
All right, guys. We're just about to
wrap up the episode. So, we're going to
sell off everything we have of value.
The Gouty Tuber did sell for 500K. The
Oium Ward did sell for a 300k profit.
So, we're ending the episode with a 11
mil, uh, which is the highest we've been
by far. Uh, so we made a lot of progress
this episode. Full graceful set
completed, which is awesome. Another
farming patch added into our farm run,
and a green cash has been acquired. I
hope you enjoyed, and I will see you
guys in the next episode.